good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast it is a beautiful
Thursday and made even more beautiful
because I'm here with Lauren the skinny
confidential
I always just call you the skinny
confidential like I never use your first
name I'm like a TSE is coming you know I
need to change my Instagram handle I
think can you guys vote and tell me if I
should change it to Lauren Everett's I
can't decide it's it's really tough but
then you still have to like take the
skinny confidential then use it for your
blog or something it's like you still
need that like tie I think yes I feel
like I do
the problem with the skinny confidential
is people think it means skinny yes and
we learned last time you were here it's
not about being skinny it's getting the
skinny on all things health and wellness
and beauty getting the juice interesting
I'm always down for a rebrand and
personally like I kind of want to drop
the problems from my Instagram handle
like the problems but like problems is
so like 2011 you know I feel like it
really dates me and I would love to be
just Jackie O and there is someone who
has the handle and I messaged her now
once a year she's never even opened my
messages
I just read all message her I don't know
how to get through to her weight I feel
like everyone should message and I don't
want to like intake I don't want to you
know if she doesn't want to give it to
me and she does post she's private but
she's like she does have posts so I
don't want to like bully her into giving
it to me like and I would obviously be
happy to pay for it but that would just
really elevate my brand I think if I
were just Jackie oh I do like problems
but I see what you're saying Jackie I
was pretty shaky I would only drop the
problems for Jackie like I wouldn't do
like Jackie ashrae or like something
else like changed my brand totally but
I'm ready to drop the prob you know I
found you on Twitter and I just
remembered this like five hundred years
ago and it was Jackie O problems hmm
that's and then that's why my Instagram
is Jackie o problem I loved your Twitter
back in the day oh my god Thanks that's
vintage I want to like I mean honestly
you're so funny oh my god thank you I
was just like in college struggling and
it's funny to struggle struggle trust me
college bartending we could talk oh my
god I just told Mimi it who's working
with me she's 21 years old and she's at
the Victoria's Secret Show and she's
interviewing all the models right now
and she's 21 years old and I'm like at
21 years old I was naked on the bar like
struggling college bar journey until it
- yeah at 21 years old I was like had
one eye closed because I slept in a
puddle of my own vomit and it I got in
my eye that way which meant that's how I
spent my 21st birthday so my birthday
was a few days ago and I was looking
through my time hop of all birthdays
past and like really every birthday of
mine has been marred by some sort of
hangover or some were being drunk
currently like too drunk and this was my
first birthday where I alcohol was not a
factor I haven't been drinking as much
just to like speed up some like weight
loss for the wedding and then like once
I stopped drinking I realized like I
liked being like I like be feeling
hydrated and like my skin being better
so that I stopped drinking like we're
going to Miami this weekend don't worry
you guys like I'll show up um but it was
like so nice to have a birthday where I
wasn't sick you know though you gotta
get drunk on your birthday I had a blast
like I had alcohol I had a glass of wine
so I thought the same thing I was like
you can't like have a totally dry
birthday without a better reason than
I'm lame and you know but you're going
to Miami so that's good you loved it up
there and we just did my bachelorette
party and I lived it up so long can we
talk about your dress at your
bachelorette party because I just told
you I was so jealous of that dress I
looked at it for like three hours I was
a dancer hiding like I want to get
married again because I saw that dress
right and it's like the best after party
truck it was it's the best dressed
period and what's funny is like so many
of the girls in the group then borrowed
it and I borrowed it from a friend and
it's The Sisterhood of the Traveling
dress like it looks good on everyone and
it would look so good on you
really it's latex I feel like it would
like hug my banana roll but it was like
loose okay or at least this one was I
looked amazing on you thank you
like I've never been more obsessed with
a dress oh my god well I've never been
more obsessed with a Halloween costume
and a wig thank you then what I never
saw the movie you know I saw it like one
eye closed Michael thinks I saw it what
I closed hangout I just like really
wanted to act really [ __ ] and she's so
[ __ ] in the movie and I felt like it
was a good time for it you know know it
Halloween like when you have a great
costume like a few years ago I dressed
up as Emma Roberts from scream queens
and I was just like
wielding my fake knife and I was having
a blast
I love every wife scream queen no yeah I
didn't watch Riverdale okay
your two favorite for you I'm gonna
prescribe scream queens first I think
you'll be obsessed with it there's only
two seasons because of course everything
I love like never makes it past a
sophomore season and then Riverdale is
amazing but it's not for everyone so
like okay but are they like I don't like
fake I like real situation okay then
maybe not Riverdale for you not revenue
but you should watch dynasty do you
watch dynasty you do look like the girl
though that stars them it does everyone
tell you that everyone tells me that and
I've been getting it like so like people
who know me tell me that because they
know that it would like make my life
complete
but then randomly like when I on my bird
like on my birthday at dinner like
someone was like do I know you from
somewhere I was like I don't know maybe
the Internet she was like are you
wanting Riverdale and I was like I wish
you do look just wake up and I was in
Austin and I was buying an ice cream and
the woman was like you look like the
girl from Riverdale and so like I know
that they were only saying it cuz they
thought it was true not because they
wanted to make me feel good I mean she
has really jewy skin and your skin is
looking insane well thanks to you
because not only dry massage my
lymphatic nodes on the regular not as
regular as I used to when you first came
on okay we'll get it going it could I
did this I did this morning and then
last night I did do the ernõ oslo's eye
patches aren't they good that I that I
keep my refrigerator now per your
recommendation love it and and and it
felt really good and then I did my cope
re
skin routine which I do all the time but
I know that you like cope re also I love
Co party you honestly like your skin is
so glowy in person like so is yours
it's the first thing I look at on anyone
I can't help it it looks amazing
there's nothing it's like from low e and
dewy and just like clear i have
hyperpigmentation you don't have
anything what does that mean look i have
brown spots all over my face oh well
what why don't someone asked a question
what do you do for dark spots it's been
such a struggle
honestly I've tried everything like I
feel like my job is is to try everything
and then report back what the best
things are and I would say laser has
really helped okay but it's so expensive
right and
time consuming yeah so I would probably
say to go with skin pseudo coals their
brand is like amazing I'm obsessed with
it right now I have their under-eye
stuff it's a good brand dr. Denis gross
I've talked about this before I love his
products okay and then eminence is
really good they have like a licorice
serum but honestly it's staying out of
the Sun and I got off birth control that
helped making it like crazy oh wow
when you have dark spots is makeup just
cover it up but you wanted like I don't
know Gracie you know you can't see
anything no Minh see it when there's no
makeup on okay it's bleep but at least
makeup it helps to thank God for makeup
and I'm like a tinted sunscreen oh yeah
that works really well to cover it up
also your hair is amazing and it's
different than it was last time because
it's more platinum love just switch it
up I'm doing more platinum right now
this is very very fake my hair's like to
hear actually I Drive like today with
short hair though
okay it would look really good like your
Halloween costume so you were Elvira
Elvira but like your wig was amazing you
also kind of looks like the mom from The
Brady Bunch but like hot mom oh my god
that's hysterical that's amazing the mom
from The Brady Bunch so do you want to
recycle the wig for next year or a
different if you have like a 70s
Halloween party to go to mom from The
Brady Bunch
okay I want to be something really funny
next year I don't want to be something
that's like hot sweaty I want to be
something that's like funny okay so if
anyone has any ideas I want to go I want
to make fun of myself you know okay
we're here for usually like maybe
something will happen this year that
will give you the inspiration that you
need yeah
what were you so I didn't really get to
celebrate Halloween cuz I wasn't here
the weekend before and then like how
about we night in New York City is awful
like you spend more time getting to
where you're trying to go because of the
parades and the people then being there
so we just I only dress up for the show
that day Claudia and I were Kim and
Kourtney yeah I saw that
and snitch was Kris it was amazing did
the whole show in their personalities
which was so fun and you had a salad and
I had a salad and you had your coffee I
had my coffee I had my straw
yeah I had um brown I had black eyebrows
which was so crazy for me you looked
really good you guys enjoyed it it
really is fun
be someone else oh it's so fun I get why
Kylie does like the wigs all the time
and once you start doing it you can't
stop it becomes addicting you have to be
careful cuz like you'll become like me
and want to change your hair platinum
and get like extensions and then you're
like oh it'd be fun to add like a stripe
of purple it is fun and if you can do it
and everything is like temporary you
know and Michael's lucky it's like a
different girl like all the time I wish
someone asked how do you and Michael
keep things spicy and that is wigs wigs
Lube porn whatever works you know
sometimes you just got to get the job
done
yeah I my stepmom I find I said this on
the last show but she told me you always
rally it's so hard it's so hard I'm so
[ __ ] dying and I'm like oh my god I
just can't and you just have to talk
yourself into it and yeah like you can
do it you know what I did the other day
is a good tip I literally had two
minutes and so I said I have two minutes
and so I said Alexa set an alarm for two
minutes and it worked really well
because it like gave them a boundary
interesting you're so busy that you only
have two minutes
no no just worked within two minutes of
each other
done yeah ask Alexa to help you out
there yeah and like she also plays the
tunes yeah she plays the tunes turn on
Frank Sinatra whoo yeah we're more of
Adele people oh I gotta try it out one
time Michael and I me actually decided
that I wanted to play the drive
soundtrack every time we had sex for
like two years I've never seen that
either you've gotta listen to the drive
soundtrack I'm not so good it's been
really good for sex okay and now
watching movie okay perfect you'll like
it and I'll watch a star is born and
scream queens pretty why do I get Pretty
Little Liars mixed up with scream queen
I don't know it's like nothing alike
yeah well I guess technically they're
both like why a pretty people but
nothing alike okay and Pretty Little
Liars it's like a million season so
confusing like swervin scream queens is
two seasons of like the best fashion you
will ever see the witty assigns it's
Ryan Murphy Emma Roberts Lea Michele
it's it's amazing okay
like you'll
and then you're gonna be sad that
there's not more of it to watch okay I'm
watching it I'm taking the prescription
cool well so we're gonna get into the
past five student and I'm gonna bombard
you with all of the questions that the
toasters have for you because you really
did change our lives last time but
you're in town for the Victoria's Secret
Fashion Show
I am so how is that going when is the
Fashion Show the fashion shows tonight
yeah it's going well I sent like I said
I sent me neither to interview some of
the models hopefully I can go back after
this and interview some of them what are
some of like your burning questions for
them I want to know all the skin secrets
cuz I think skin is obviously so in and
the lights are in their face um I want
to know diet secrets but I do think like
everyone has the same answer it's they
up their protein they up their veggies
they up their fiber then they cut
alcohol it's pretty boring I just feel
like I want someone to be like I haven't
eaten in five days honestly that would
be like cool if someone just came out
and said that you know do you did you
watch Madol squad the reality show on E
I watched one okay I watched the season
and I really enjoyed it and I found it
very interesting and Nadine and a lot of
the models like Devin ones are like
really does eat what she wants but like
Nadine who just got her first BS fashion
show last year on Milo squad she's
walking again this year was talking
about how like when she'd went up for
casting like that week like she
literally hadn't eaten all week like she
was just being really real about it and
then later in the season like talked
about how she struggled with eating
disorder and I just feel like that's how
we think like I hate when models try to
be like oh like you know we're eating
cookies backstage like no you're not
I did hear Bella Hadid eats whatever she
wants yeah I think there are a few well
I don't know because she there's a few
lucky ones there's Emily I feel like
kendall Jenner eats whatever she wants
and honestly she's always looked the
same way twice but I feel like there are
models who have clearly lost weight and
then they say they eat whatever they
want yeah yeah you know I would say
start with intermittent fasting that's
what I've been doing lately okay and I
feel like it's made a big difference
it's not starving yourself though people
get it confused yes giving your
digestive system break so I think a lot
of the models do that I'm gonna get the
juice on it okay yeah please do I will I
will I'm gonna get like every secret who
are some of your favorite like angels
and people walking at your head
I really like this girl Sara but I don't
know where elastic sampaio I think
that's her last name she's beautiful
yeah I feel like if I was a lesbian like
that that's being my father style yeah
cool and then of course like all the the
regular ones that everyone loves I can't
wait to see their costumes though same I
hope they do a good job I hope I'm
excited for the music well I'm excited
you'll be their lives so I'm excited for
you to enjoy the music live should I
live stream it oh no
I personally I I guess I don't really
watch that many live streams but I don't
know it's clearly a lot of people do but
maybe just stories huh stories yeah I
think so
stories and like maybe an Instagram yeah
so when you got invited to the Fashion
Show they're doing like a lot of
influence or activations around this and
I don't know that they always have cuz
it's like hard to you know bring on
these influencers to China but we're in
New York so there's a lotta influencers
this year someone said there was like a
rumor that they might have an influencer
walk potentially in the future don't
worry it's not gonna be me who do you
think might be oh I don't know maybe a
Livia Coco yeah yeah cause like she's
dabbling and modeling her face is just
the golden ratio you know it's like so
symmetrical and beautiful and I think
did you see the Instagram story where
she should watch yes happy birthday to
her I loved that mm-hmm I think I like I
love that it's like it's a dig but it's
like a classy day it is and she is
really classy and like Oh like brand
conscious you know say she wouldn't ever
just post something she wouldn't never
could just go off on her stories but it
just gave us a hint like we're broken up
I'm bitter I have a new watch and it
would have been yours and I'm a good
gift giver yep and like what is he doing
who cheats on Olivia coulple I don't
know I saw the best quote in our
Facebook group it was like it's not
about the woman if they cheat it's about
what kind of man yeah and their
integrity and that's so true yeah cause
like if you're gonna cheat on Olivia
cold like right it's not right it's not
cuz you're looking for something better
no it's just you're looking for yourself
it's pretty crazy
anyways without further ado and then we
will bombard you continue to bombard you
with questions here are the fast five
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast I wish I could have
morning toast for you would be your
morning GG cracker or a morning
sourdough depends on the day what's so
great about sourdough trader joe's
cracked wheat sourdough which carry gold
butter and pink salt is next level and
I'm sorry I just added five pounds to
everyone really okay pink sauce you're
so unbanned I can't even
okay first story is a story that I'm
really excited about and also I'm
excited to get your take on because
Oprah's entire 2018 list of favorite
things has been revealed and there is a
lot to get through but I want to get
your take on some of the beauty ones and
everything else because there's a lot of
favorite things and I and I do wonder
like how sponsored I was just gonna say
that yeah I feel it she definitely I
feel like if it we're all sponsored it
wouldn't have the same effect but she
definitely gets what's it called like
affiliate link promo code she definitely
gets kickbacks when you use kind of
Oprah okay so that's okay affiliate
codes okay with me yes me too so like as
long as she's still doing the choosing
she has a lot of cozy things robes
hoodies pajamas socks here for all of
that but like it's not hard to be cozy
you know does she have a barefoot dreams
blanket she does not have it she has a
Peace Love world shag throws with
pom-poms no she's missing out she really
needs to get a leopard barefoot dreams
blanket ones the Kardashians have oh
nothing's better it's the best gifts you
guys if you need a gift okay also and
then I want to get like what your
favorite things would be but for a
family gift she has some mugs she has
some family pajamas she has some
suitcases I actually didn't need a
suitcase recommendation and I wound up
just getting in a way okay because
everyone I would like got lazy is it
good I haven't been taken out of the box
yet it looks cute though but I just feel
like this is my thing with suitcases
like I rarely check luggage so I need a
carry-on I Karen can get me through a
week vacation as long as it's not like a
ski vacation with moon boots and peppers
okay I need a carry-on that holds the
maximum amount of things possible while
still being
sure for TSA and I do feel like
hardshell limits you because with a
softshell top like you can shove it in
there you're not gonna like this cuz
it's not cute to me to me cute it's just
expensive right it's expensive but it's
worth it because it's something that
you'll have forever
okay to miss they're not cute it's cute
it's just it's not like painting me away
Timmy's cute it's like she yeah I did
get the pink away under I mean well it's
good for the feed its ya know so now I'm
not gonna happen now I'm gonna have to
wear makeup to the airport so I can take
a picture yes it's actually not good for
the skin but I act so we are my family
we've been obsessed with Kipling's like
since Kipling was relevant and now like
we sit like the Kipling carrion is
actually the most space per carry on
ever like you can fit so much in there
soft top like literally not at an inch
of space
bring it back but they are just so not
cute and like I've been using it up
until last week and I just can't walk
around with it anymore and I monkey
hanging off monkey hanging off the works
and I do need like a four-wheeler the
four wheel is revolutionary
you know what Kipling's not bad because
that puts less pressure on you don't do
makeup at the airport and then like no
one's gonna steal your bag
ya don't have Michael any ideas it's
like his worst nightmare
someone's stealing yeah yeah that's
right like you also don't want to have
nice luggage yeah you don't want to
travel with too nice it's for checked
luggage yeah definitely per carry on
like just keep your [ __ ] together you
should be okay well let's bring the
Kipling back it's kind of Vaughn Duchy
true okay
I'll submit you're not there say maybe
if they have some updated ones with four
wheels yeah perhaps or if not Kipling
you know Kipling you never know who's
watching yeah um
speaking of free stuff that mosquito
speaking of not getting free stuff the
mosquito H&M collection came out this
morning and I actually set an alarm to
get some [ __ ] online and when I four
eight eight o'clock and it was not
available it like nothing was up the
website wasn't working and then I
checked again a few like 15 minutes
later not working in between like
sleeping and then when I finally got on
it like 9:00 so much [ __ ] was sold out
like I didn't get anything I feel like
you have to go to eBay for that it's a
little bit more expensive but then it's
like
prices were already like not totally hmm
like there was there was a bag that was
$600 like if I'm spending $600 I Massena
like I'm just gonna get the high couture
yeah is it or is it like really cute
some of it it's not like if I'm if I
don't get one thing I'll I will live but
there are some like really cute t-shirts
and sweat suits and it's like I'm never
gonna buy a Couture sweat suit but it's
like I can wear a mosquito sweat suit
that only cost me like less $100 I'm
down here's what you should do you
should delegate it out so you should say
to your fiance how much you want this
and how much it means to you and for a
gift Oh and then to make him get on the
site at the exact time and make him do
it so you can sleep true I guess I think
that that's not what I would I would
that's not my son no I asked what's your
wish
well I got got my birthday present but
my next big wish said I don't know will
ever come true is a dog come true well
here's the problem so my Zach like
doesn't love dogs and he hates shedding
and the only dog I'm interested in
having in my life is the King Charles
Cavalier spaniel the same dog that
claudia has and the same dog that we
grew up with like i'm not even a dog
lover I'm a King Charles lover so that's
the only dog I'm interested in he hates
shedding and they shed the most and he
can't get a dog that sheds so like we're
here and here and so the compromise
would be to get a different dog but I'm
not interested in a different dog okay
can you just borrow Claudia's dog for a
week make him fall in love with that dog
and then go from there that's been
that's what I've been more Han for the
past year and a half and like he's he's
immune to his charms you need a deep
sigh manipulation that's ongoing so it's
like you're at dinner and everything's
perfect and you're like you know what
would make dinner so much better and
everything would just be perfect and
then like make him like ask for it and
be like a king Charles and like that
needs to happen over and over like
little things like that like I always
say it's like a little like you're like
chipping away away at the manipulation
sometimes it takes years I've had ones
that I've had on going for like three
years but they end up with water years
ooh
like when I first started dating Michael
I wanted him to get
retainer why just because like there was
like some like crooked situations are my
bottom teeth freaking you out no your
teeth are looking great my bottom teeth
are so crooked and I just keep letting
make you look youthful don't do anything
and that's what you want to look
youthful you look adorable yeah my teeth
are very Miley Cyrus circa Hannah
Montana movie crooked but um it hasn't
started bothering I still think it gives
character it doesn't look like oh she
wasn't as gentle insurance yeah which I
don't but you know you don't know that
yet so what was your over in Taner
retainer oh that one yeah Botox we got
in Botox I think last time I was here we
worked working on it yeah oh where did
he get it dr. Denis gross and in his far
in his forehead we just did five units
so he didn't go crazy okay and then he
was acting as if he had had a full
facelift afterwards so just like little
ones the Botox one took eight years Wow
yeah so sometimes you have to commit to
it why did you really want him to get it
cuz like the wrinkles were just I just
think he has like a kind of a curse that
line like not in a mean way and I think
as a beauty blogger you know just try a
little just yeah see how it does oh yeah
you know and he liked it good he didn't
mind it
I just got fresh Botox and I'm so
obsessed my forehead doesn't move and I
couldn't be happier and it also really
helped with I was getting really bad
migraines at night and now I haven't had
them since
so it's medicinal it's medicinal it
looks great thank you
youthful thank you okay back to Oprah
for beauty lovers okay this is really
where I want to get your take the Sunday
Riley game-changer kit body butter and
dry body oil sets library of thought
flowers by Margot Alayna bubble bath
artis elite mirror ten piece brush set
which looks like the bad knee Planet
brushes but with a higher price tag
julep Beauty divine shine lip gloss
Collection Clarisonic Mia Smart Lux
goat's milk bar soap gift boxes lash
aunt Elaine deluxe hand cream set guilty
pleasures ultimate nail lacquer stash
thoughts do you know of any of these
things the goat's milk sounds amazing I
try that use code
for 20% off okay and what was the one
before the goat smell Clarisonic Mia
smart lux not Oprah needs to get on the
uplift yeah I really I do feel as though
these are not choices that are really in
tune with with what's going on in the
beauty realm right now like a Jade
roller yeah perhaps she could have done
a Jade roller maybe an ice roller mm-hmm
I don't know I feel like she should have
gone with the uplift the brush is kind
of out I feel yeah you know yeah and if
you guys have the brush at home watch
out the head for the uplift and we want
to drink the lymph nodes yeah we do want
to drain traveler treats a down pillow
for traveling power Bell fold up bags
Clark backpack and duffel foot nanny
travel set with green buffer that looks
kind of nice um k Carol accessories
Harper crossbody bags okay fashionable
finds none of these things look
fashionable to me some nice slippers but
that's not I'm sorry but a hoodie a
fleece peplum full zip hoodie jacket is
not fashionable find for the kitchen a
bunch of [ __ ] not exciting to me food
gifts Oh
artisanal popcorn she's really into so I
love I love popcorns my favorite
finishing so good popcorn and hot dogs
oh I should go to more baseball game
weird yeah where do you get a hot dog
that's really good in New York oh well
for me so because I only top kosher hot
dogs okay um so they're like honestly
it's best when it's like a Hebrew
national that like is grill that in the
home or like on a barbecue I'm like what
is on your hot dog
oh honey Dijon mustard sauerkraut simple
no ketchup no ketchup really mm-hmm
okay Wow that must be a West Coast thing
maybe a jalapeno
I don't know pack with spicy that much
okay yeah even though I should speed up
my metabolism tech gadgets okay this is
where echo spot Quran catch wireless
charging accessory toys the iPhone XR q
LED TV Apple earpods just got a pair and
I really do recommend them they do use
their pads Michael does I want them to
distract you burrs ooh interesting
they've monocle yeah no they really are
better than had like they're worth the
investment and I do feel like unlike
headphones you won't lose them because
that you spend so much on them and like
if you're getting a manicure or
something you can like listen to things
and you know the wires not getting in
your way
you can set your phone somewhere and
then walk around and listen to stuff
like I really do feel like it's great
and it's definitely helping the podcast
realm for our spot casters I think you
should do Jackie O favorite things for
Christmas I do think so too yeah I like
your recommendations better than Oprah
okay I'm gonna work on it gifts for the
home picture a pitcher a grower and
Christmas tree kit a bamboo bedding
bundle or a Wi-Fi smart frames Oh a
smart frame what's that like I think
where the pictures change in the frame
okay um I'm kind of into that because I
really do intend to get my picture frame
spilled in but it's like where am I
gonna go to the printer store stressful
- yeah it's just a lot there are a lot
of there are a lot of things on her list
and honestly I'm not impressed well do
you think it's Oprah I think that Oprah
like has to give final say because this
is one of her bigger things things of
the year so if it's totally like not
Oprah what is she working on you know
yeah that's true you know it's our
in-person at what's that restaurant
called shikko knees skin lymph nodes are
drained really yeah immediately skin
glowing good for her so maybe we should
get her Beauty pics Sunday Riley after
she just recommended it now I think I
want to try it you should yeah so what
would be on your favorite things like
foreskin for life for life definitely
the Erno lens Oh am I saying that right
I see I think so or no Laszlo's I don't
know you use them the idea and I use
them like I had them before you told me
that you use them and I already likes
them and now I love them and I keep them
in the fridge so it does double duty the
fridge is the best tip and you can like
put them on even when you're showering
to be efficient with time yeah and do
like a hot cold shower it's like a spa I
also really like this cleansing balm I
feel like you would love it it's by
Elemis and it's like
Glaus but it's balm for your face and
it's not sticky and it removes makeup in
one swipe oh wow yeah like that and then
if you want to get something cheap to
remove makeup grapeseed oil that's the
best well you use olive oil olive
whatever whatever oil you can get your
hands on the problem with oil that when
we discussed this earlier is it takes
the spray tan off oh it's the struggle
again yeah
the spray tan struggle is really we're
talking about like trying to figure out
when to get a spray tan is like that
meme of all the math like between
getting with your waxes your manicure
pedicure double trip tints I can't it's
too much and then if you're going on
vacation like the minute you got into a
pool it's gone yes so what do you do it
like I don't know and I say I got a
spray tan last week for for Halloween
and I haven't like gone swimming or been
in the ocean so it's like still on and I
need it not to be yeah it's it's it's
only good for like two days it's just so
stressful and then you also don't want
to wipe your face you're like should I
sleep in my makeup and be really bad
yeah the face goes first
oh that's so annoying and cuz I always
do my face a little lighter anyway it's
gone and then like with this new hair
color the spray tan like sometimes gets
in it interesting yeah so it's like a
whole it is like a whole situation yeah
stressful if anyone has any tips let us
know yeah seriously and it's like the
spray head last two days but you can't
get a spray tan a second one three days
later because then you're just like
clumps and you have like the the hand
stuff yet like all over the hand my
first tip is you gotta wash the hands
the second you're done yes I put lotion
on my hand so it doesn't even stick that
well like I would rather have like pale
hands and the line then like orange
fingers totally and we have the same
bracelet and that always makes the line
so much worse it's still here you know
like because I wear it like here yeah
you try to like let it dangle like this
you're like yeah I wish I could do like
a spray tan tutorial but naked and like
show it's like I have like two shower
caps on because I'm like protecting my
roots and then really [ __ ] I need a
bikini yeah I could do in a bikini but
then you get the line right where it's
so stressful yeah nothing's more
stressful no
next story about we're only on story
story - we couldn't be moving slower
halsy ends john mayer romance rumors ok
so there was like a rumor going around
that Jose and John Mayer were hitting it
off but the badet loves singers shot
down rumors she and Mayer are in a
relationship following her split from
gez quote I just had a groundbreaking
idea what if we what if we let female
artists have friends without assuming
they're sleeping together she tweeted on
Wednesday I know I know it's like
completely ambitious but like imagine if
we tried lol Shaw day honestly I never
thought they were together like they
were commenting on each other's
instagrams but like John Mayer does that
with everyone he does that with everyone
and I got major juice from your group
that group is amusing amazing oh my gosh
sometimes at night I just like sit in my
bed and read through it no say they are
saying that John Mayer likes to pee on
people yeah on girls
interesting did you see that post no I
didn't goggle search John Mayer pee in
your group okay that makes sense because
people have like alluded to the fact
that he is into some weird stuff you
know I think they get bored yes I know
okay whatever whatever you want it's
like it's like hair next you know yeah
you start to experiment and then you're
like next thing you know you have a buzz
cut like you know Demi yes
a dummy more oh I say min Demi Lovato
and she did like no Demi Moore remember
and GI Jane yes you never know you never
really never know yeah I don't see these
two as match I feel like Halsey and
jay-z will continue to get back together
um
and John Mayer will continue to leave
comments on Instagram agreed at least
she doesn't face tune anymore yeah
thanks I was so fun that was a weird
time that was like what everyone's face
tuning but no one was talking about the
fact that it was out of control
you know it was like still up like a
secret and now it's an open secret
everyone I was at a party last night
everyone's face tuning yeah or even on
Kardashians when Kendall was like two
Scott I can face too near bulge bigger
and it's like kendall Jenner uses face
tune and knows how to use the reshape so
you know what we're all in the same boat
a little refine yeah detail reshape is
is there's refine reshape and my
favorites the white and yes the whites
of the eyes
I'm gonna have to talk about flow we'll
talk about that towards the end because
I recently learned how to use presets
which ones are you using
I bought a million presets on Etsy
because I like didn't want to spend $80
on blogger presets and I'm on time
spending $80 on a million presets from
Etsy but I'm glad because I use a
different one for well use kind of the
same ones but each photo I'll just use
whatever preset is the best for the job
okay you know is it flowing it's flowing
so my flow rate my flow on my bachelor
party was like that's so love premium
and and everyone I made that's how I
party like we were all talking about
flow and like we were all doing each
other's picture so we were all looking
good together and now it's hard in the
winter flow is hard in the winter
especially in the city the city is not
cute for pictures and if you take a lot
of nighttime pictures you know what you
have to do you have to do flash now I
think flash isn't flash in an uber OH
what do you mean like use the flash on
your iPhone in an uber with a because
the backgrounds black use the flash yeah
like you slash yeah but but you slush
yes you take that away but have the
person taking the photo sit in the front
seat that's the trick okay quick you
don't want to be a cross like yes cuz
then it like you're so red eye and skin
and hairline and it's all weird it's you
end up looking like a Brady Bunch person
like yourself yes my person was across
from me no you looked amazing in that
picture little Brady Bunch you though
no just the wig was Brady Bunch II like
cuz if it looks like Mary Carol but I
was here for it I really was and like
every year you could go with someone
different like next year he could be
Marcia okay you're after he can be
jammed
okay just never do that okay um [ __ ]
what were we talking Oh we'll get to
that next story why Kourtney Kardashian
agreed to have dinner with Scott Disick
and Sophia Richie okay so the other day
Kourtney Scott and Sophia went to Nobu
Malibu for dinner and to the untrained
eye it was the first time Kourtney had
met like with Scott and Sophia and
agreed to sit down I don't think it's
the first I don't think it's the first
time either I think it's like now
they're fine letting us know that
they're fine everything's the strategy
like especially this land analogy they
didn't accidentally bump into each other
and Nobu Malibu which has the most pop
season la right no just a pawn yeah in
their games yeah totally
but I do think like now that they're
letting us know that they're all
co-parenting I do think it really like
propels gotten Sophia's relationship
like they're legit they've been together
over a year now
like starting Sophia yeah I think it's I
don't trust real thing you don't trust
him
do you watch Kardashians hmm why don't
you trust him what do you think his
intentions are I might have some some
scoop some scoop maybe I can share it in
the group okay but like just just us now
like I don't trust him I don't think
he's cheating yeah I think everyone
cheats in Hollywood that's just like
that's like zero you know zero is I
cheat a lot of understandings I think
yes I agree I don't she might like there
might be an understanding happening it's
like when you're not around ya know and
I think that that rings true for like
most celebrity relationships even like
Chloe and Tristan but what was so [ __ ]
about up about Tristan is that like one
he was like cheating on her the week
that she's giving birth and he's like
not even being smart about it because no
one was like how like on the episode
where it all came out no one was like oh
my god like how is Tristan cheating on
Chloe they were like why is he doing
this now and like why why so publicly
yeah I think that there's a lot of
understandings you know mm-hmm I think
the pregnancy thing was like come on man
keep it in your pants like for like one
week
I mean God we're at least like not in at
a club yeah it's it's just humiliating
for her probably and then so much stress
on the baby too but I don't think she
was like shocked to find out that he had
cheated that he was a cheater no were
you shocked I mean was anyone shocked no
no but just that like he sometimes guys
to look sloppy yeah you know yeah I feel
like with athletes especially like even
Olivia and Danny Amendola it really is
like sometimes you sign up for like you
know a tough pill that you have to
swallow yes anyways
despite busy schedules the Keeping Up
with the Kardashians star headed to Nobu
and now the one Sunday night where she
met Scott Disick for dinner Wow today's
Thursday we're really behind on this
story but it only just started an
interest
me when I found out that it was their
billing it is the first time they're all
meeting and it's at Nobu Malibu so it's
like neither of those things are true
yeah I think that it's a setup it sounds
a little Kris Jenner II yeah
Scott Sophie and Courtney had dinner
together on nope at Nobu on Sunday and
it was very amicable a source shared
with enews Scott and Sophia are very
serious and Scott felt it was important
that Sophia and Kourtney interact and
bond our insider continued they have
kept set they have kept things separate
for over a year now and Kourtney is now
more open and willing to have a surface
level relationship with Sophia yeah I
just feel like this is like a new era
for their relationship and I wouldn't be
surprised if we we like start see her
next season on Kardashians I think she's
here to stay should we make a bet I
don't think so so you don't think she'll
be on the show or that they won't be
together I don't I can't imagine her on
the show you think she'll be on the show
I just I feel like they need they're
running like things are gonna run a joke
yeah I'm like she would be perfect for
the show she talks about her on the show
anyway like let's see her she's a cutie
I like her style
I would watch okay maybe you're right
we'll have to see in a year you have to
come back on our podcast yeah we'll see
we'll see I'm a patient you know yeah
I'll remember this yeah oh yeah oh yeah
okay we'll see okay next story speaking
of you know more parenting drama Chris
Pratt and Anna Faris's divorce dictates
that they live five miles apart Chris
Pratt and Anna Faris won't be out of
each other's sight for at least five
years after coming to a divorce
agreement with the help of a private
judge Pratt and Faris agreed to live no
more than five miles apart according to
documents obtained by TMZ the clause
calls for the rule to stay in place
until six-year-old jack completes the
sixth grade should they have to move
farther apart they have to give the
other party written notice no later than
three months in advance of the move the
former couple also has to provide 30
days notice that either wants to travel
out of the country with Jack and gave
quote reasonable advance notice to
travel out of state interesting you know
whatever works for them and makes sense
and I don't think either of them are
gonna go far out of Hollywood
considering they both work there yeah I
think if that works for them like they
should do that I can't imagine getting a
divorce so publicly now I mean that's
tough especially when you were like such
relationship goals for the rest of the
world
so long yeah that's it's got to be
really really hard I mean I don't think
there's anything really harder than
going through a public divorce and
having every one way and and then also
having a kid yeah and she on her podcast
always talked about him so it's like
yeah things have to be like really bad
for you to throw in the towel when like
it's at that level
yeah like so many people look to your
relationship and so many people are
invested in it which is like weird for
us but here we are I mean I think
they're making the right decision for
them I think so too and their kid is
really cute and I feel like they're cool
ish crazy Oh Maddie you know like I feel
like they're there it's not like that
bad between them but he has like a new
lady love I love his lady love yeah she
is like she's cool she's good you know
her we interviewed her on the podcast
interesting what did she do she she's
Katherine's fortune eager yeah she just
wrote a book it's so cute it's about
maverick and me it's about a rescue yes
it's comic that's cute yeah she's
adorable and she's good with lovey and
has lots of charisma cool does she have
a kid no isn't she like 26 I'm not sure
how old she is I guess I don't have a
kid and I could write a kids book yeah
it would be great at writing a kids
about you would be like something about
a piece of toast oh my god yeah oh my
god you have to do that
the redhead like it's a redhead totally
like a cute redhead wearing a pink latex
dress a cute child wearing a latex dress
wait speaking of children our fifth and
final story is really kind of wild Girl
Scouts sooo Boy Scouts over programs
name change the Girl Scouts of the
United States of America filed a
trademark infringement lawsuit on Monday
against the Boy Scouts of America
for dropping the word boy from its
flagship program in an effort to attract
girls in the complaint filed in
Manhattan federal court the Girl Scouts
claimed the program quote does not have
a right under either federal or New York
law to use terms like Scouts are
scouting by themselves in connection
with services offered to girls or to
rebrand itself as quote the scouts Scots
such misconduct will not only cause
confusion mount among the public damage
to the goodwill of gs USA's Girl Scouts
trademarks and wrote its core brand
identity but it will also marginalize
the Girl Scouts movement by causing the
public to believe that GS USA's
extraordinarily successful services
are not true or official quote scouting
programs but niche services with limited
utility and appeal wow this is dramatic
but is dramatic like turning on each
other you know I think it would have
been fun to join the Boy Scouts when I
was little and I do feel like they're
very different like my boys got
stem-cell cookies no they don't sell
cookies and they do like lots of camping
yeah speaking of camp cure camp camp
toast
that's like heavy weights kind of know
the jump thing what's that thing kabob
yeah we don't have a blob but we had oh
we did have them my god it has that
thing Camp Nowhere like vine and then
today the campgrounds are the grounds of
a fat camp where we went to camp amazing
and that like was heavy weights as they
saw both no way mm-hmm oh my god but
something actually I that's a theory of
mine but it seems true because like the
owner's name is Tony in the movie and in
our camp and it is the like preeminent
number-one fat camp in the country so
why would you they set off like why
don't you do when you go to fat camp
well it really is an amazing amazing
place and we loved it and when we went
we weren't even overweight but like so
there's people there who are there to
lose weight and they do in many
different ways from like eating right
just walking around and then also
exercising and then there are people
there who are trying to get in shape for
like sports or are supporting a sibling
who's there to lose weight so if you're
not there to lose weight between like
they do feed you a lot like an 1800
calorie a day diet which is like more
than I would eat it so they're not
restrictive know what's cool like and
the food is so good but you are just
like doing something like you workout in
the morning and then the rest of the
day's activities the campgrounds are
huge so you're just walking around and
like for a larger person that you'll
lose weight and me for an average-sized
person like it's just regular activity
and if you're used to that you don't I
never like lost weight as a camper cuz
I'd like it wasn't your like one pound
oh my god I wish you're looking really
good
thanks shedding for the wedding how are
you shouting for the wedding um pretty
much like Atkins keto during the week
like I'm very good and very strict and
then on the weekends I do like eat what
I want so that during the week like I'm
even better and now the trend like what
Monday oh it depends that so like it's
not even like what how much I eat it's
like I can only eat a few things and
then of those things I can eat as much
as I'm feeling but like a lot of nuts a
lot of cheese strings fish meat out
sometimes do like a cottage cheese after
the show okay um you have to try to get
all the Barkers I tried them do you not
like them they taste a little farty to
me yeah they're farty they're flirty but
like enjoying a cracker you know it's
and so I'll do an Atkins bar on a day
where I like need chocolate sometimes if
I'm like really hungry I'll have some
halo top even though it's not totally
carb free it's like better than
something else I've never tried that
join you too yes okay we're enlightened
it's all the same okay ready much some
flavors are better than others but if
you're like trying to lose weight it's
like if you eat a pint of that you're
fine
versus eating a pint of Ben and Jerry's
okay what's your favorite flavor oatmeal
raisin which is weird that's so random
so random I want to try it yeah or
oatmeal cookie sorry there's no reason
cuz you could sprinkle some nuts on top
you could yeah cuz you can have nuts
okay sometimes I'll do like a scoop of
peanut butter if I'm like really hungry
it just it depends on the day okay but
then like knowing that Saturday design
it like if I'm creating pasta like I
don't know I can have it on Saturday or
Sunday I can I can make it three you can
live yeah and what about alcohol well
when you're doing kita alcohol like
vodka tequila it doesn't have any carbs
you could technically drink as much as
you want wine has like a little bit of
carbs but still you could drink it but
for me I find like when I when I drink
it dehydrates you which is not good for
weight loss and then the next day like
if you're feeling shitty you just like
make worse choices
mhm so it's not about the drinking
calories it's like how it affects the
rest of like your 24 hours totally so
that's why cutting it out has just been
like major I had that make its you so
puffy
yeah like red wine I puff up like a
Blowfish I mean I don't sleep as well
like it's not real sleep yeah I agree I
like CBD lately is that the like stuff
that's in marijuana yeah like a little
it's it's like doesn't get you high yeah
relaxes you yeah that sounds lovely
yeah it's you should get on it's like
little drops under your tongue oh yeah I
can get on Amazon yeah it's like green
leaf or green Rhodes world and it's like
really good under the tongue
I works like a charm I'm here for ya
well now that you're in well you've
always lived in California have a now
you're in LA so where you just like
opened up to the world of Mary Jay it's
it's crazy I mean we went for Oh Mary
Jane but you just la la like celebrity
oh that time marijuana well yeah I've
never been the biggest um person into
marijuana I don't have anything against
it I just feel like for me it makes me
eat but I do like CBD interesting I'm
not a matter one a prisoner and don't
have anything else it is just like if I
want to smoke
I want to chill out I'll just chill out
yeah you know yeah I like a glass of
wine err tequila shot yeah you know yes
so how's been living in LA LA we just
got like fully moved in three days ago I
left Michael with everything in chaos
and came to New York when you get home
is it gonna be done now like is he gonna
do wall up like is he gonna unpack
everything just like the little
manipulations like oh I'd really love
the TV hum when I'm back or oh it's
really sucks not to have music in the
house right now like those kinds of
things I think he's get like going on
but I don't want him to touch anything I
want to organize everything yes oh like
even the kitchen and he did his books
and I wanted them color-coded and he
decided to do it by John Woo instead so
it's like not aesthetically pleasing at
least genre that is so like labor it's
harder than colors yeah I wish I wish he
did colors okay that's easy to fix
yeah it's behind the door so what
prompted the move so he has a company
called deer media and we have to move up
there for that and then I just feel like
it's the next step it's such a hustle
city mm-hmm you're a hustler yeah San
Diego was getting slow but I still love
San Diego and will probably get a
one-bedroom there just to be around our
friends and family oh nice yeah West
Hollywood's fun though you guys have to
come out I know we're gonna plan on like
it's like you know I don't go for up to
LA three years at a time and then I go
three times in one month I love it I
love it's just like how life works
sometimes okay now I'm gonna get to all
of our viewer questions for you because
we need your expertise what are your
skincare tips for someone on a budget
like and what's one thing that's worth
I'm definitely oils
go to the supermarket and get
cold-pressed grapeseed oil it's like 6
bucks ok so you need an oil ok um
something else that's on a budget I
would say Elemis has a lot of great
products that are affordable like
they're super food oil is awesome the
cleansing balms really great it doesn't
break the bank one product that I would
invest in right now I'm having this
moment with the cee skin suta Kohl's it
smells like hot dog water but like in a
good way you would like it really
what is our color what is it just a
moisturizer no it's like I don't I'm
probably saying what it is aam that
you're talking about no it's like this
thin someone needs to help me out here
with what it's like almost an acid I
guess it's serum kind of yeah and it's a
very thin layer and there's something
about it and I can just feel it working
but I would say I was a tip that's free
is use your hands for facial massage
yeah facial manipulation will contour
you like a Kardashian it really does I
literally cannot put on makeup it's like
putting makeup on a pig if I don't do it
I'm telling you so how many times a day
do you massage your lymphatic nodes I
the first thing I do when I wake up is I
will meditate and while I'm meditating
sometimes I'll just take my massager and
massage my face but if I don't have it I
can use my hands yeah I mean I would
like to do it for 10 minutes in the
morning and then at night I'll just do
it with my skincare i'm i'm telling you
facial manipulation it's free i try to
do it with my skincare at night like
when i'm just like in bed like putting
on face moisturizer i thank you every to
massage your minutes okay I need that
roller good you get a vibrator off
Amazon well after you came I did and I
got a terrible one because it like
required batteries and then it like died
after like 30 seconds so I kept I was
using all my batteries I was like no no
get the little tiny pink one I'll send
you the one I came with like a clicker
that's why no no no no it was ten you
don't want to be like full-on dildo on
your face no more like it was Tara I get
it
but I would you know I really did try
okay if you could only pick one skincare
product for the rest of your life
besides sunscreen what would it be
specific with brand - oh that's such a
good one
definitely oils I would say like a
really good high quality oil like if I'm
being honest I'd love to go to like
Italy to a vineyard and find an oil
that's like cold-pressed there
I think oil is like very much the key to
use I mean think about it when you're
sleeping and you put all that oil on
your face it's setting in and really
helps fine lines wrinkles I also love
ice like it fights inflammation so much
Kate Moss does you know like a bowl of
ice and just dunk your head in it it's
gonna tighten and wake your lymphatic
system up you know what's so crazy like
I'm looking at you and I have no clue
how old you are you go ahead oh my god
thinking about it like you're just like
ageless like you could be that's what
you could be 30 I have no idea
18 you can be eighteen twelve yeah these
aren't 12 also but when you were here
last time you were about to go in for
your breasts fix-up I got what is it
collaging you recover was it like it was
so informative it's like it's like a
medical show you know I hope I hope it
is I think that there has to be some
kind of takeaway for the people that are
spending time watching my content like
there has to be stuff that people can
take away and apply to their own life
like it has a always say it has to
educate entertain or inspire it really
was educational good
I'm so glad and I love when people
really like show it like the beginning
middle and end of their like results
process like Claudia always talks about
her her old chin we were joking about on
the show and she don't cry Bella no she
did like um cuz Cabello like we heard
was like too painful but dr. Sharon
Jeezy does like this natural chin lift
okay and it just completely like changed
Claudia's life in like every like its if
you need a new chin I recommend it
highly
then lift lipo like what is a chin lift
I don't know like it I guess it would be
like lipo of the chin Oh
I don't I never sat in on the
information sessions but that sounds to
be like the most and the closest to what
it was I feel like you need a morning
toast that's just themed around the chin
and we like really good to know the
doctor who did it I would like to like
see know she's amazing and she did my
botox and anything else I'll need soon I
don't know yet
I'm getting crazy I think I was a waste
I haven't seen or heard from anyone who
has good things to say except for a
Britney Cartwright said that she did it
and she looks great but I think she also
just lost weight yeah I think the
kybella is a lot of pain from what I've
heard and it blows you up like a
pufferfish like like a toad and it
doesn't work as well as just going in
for like a chin lipo right and you have
to do it twice so you've experienced the
pain you don't want to do it again but
like it's like jury duty like if you
don't go for the second day it doesn't
count and then you get summoned once
every six months and you can't go
because you have a morning show and now
you're going in March yeah yeah like
some people yeah yeah how do you balance
your home life and your work life and
all that you do I don't I don't
does it help working with your husband
coz like you're spending quality time
together working it helps them it
doesn't help I mean there's a lot of
times where we're in bed late night and
you know he can't turn it off or I can't
turn it off yeah it's definitely
something that we're learning - I hate
the word balance but like learning to
balance it's like a practice every day
yeah I've just really realized that
right now and this time in my life I
need to put my head down and hustle my
ass off and that's gonna change it's
just a chapter right now so we're both
like kind of committed to that we'll see
how it goes I don't have balance though
I don't want people to think that like I
mean it's work mode right now
okay but if you're both in that mode
then you're both doing like what you
want to be doing yes um no one's gonna
tell Alexa to put a two-minute timer on
that right now
yes um what question for me because you
guys do your podcast together you
interview so many people who is someone
that really like like surprised you that
you like learned the most from that you
just thought was like the most
aside from Claudia and I of course like
the most interesting interview that just
was surprising well you and Claudia sing
a little mermaid with
oh yeah so that was major yeah
especially because you have red hair so
it was like perfect um Justin Anderson
he he does my hair he colors it and he
came on our podcast and I was thinking
it was gonna be like this hair based
podcast and it just it was such a
compelling interview and I think he's
such a compelling person um what makes
him so compelling is he has strength and
warmth you know that I think that's like
it's you just like want to know more and
he really opened up on our podcast so if
you're gonna start with any episode
that's the one I would start with okay
cool what are your tips on confidence
and any tips for improving
self-confidence just wake up and decide
to be confident it really is a decision
fake it till you make it fake it till
you make it just wake up and decide that
today you're gonna focus all your energy
on being confident and you know try not
to play the victim and live in the
narrative and and and just let it fuel
you it's practice it confidence this
practice I think yeah I mean I practice
it it every decision you made yeah
totally and you if you catch yourself
scrolling through social media or
something that's not conductive to
building the confidence like check
yourself before you wreck yourself
agreed did you find a location with good
lighting for the TSE office
we haven't found an office yet we're
looking if you're like everywhere in LA
has good lighting no what no it took me
so long to find the place we're moving
into I don't care about size I don't
care about anything all I want was no
carpet and good light I'll live in a box
just give me a good light I agree it's
hard I that's so crazy cuz I feel like
all these like Instagram models in LA
are always in good light and like
everyone in New York is just like their
pictures are great I actually shouldn't
complain because New York is it's way
worse mm-hmm but it that's my arm oh my
god I was like I have two minutes no I I
was actually very very very hard to find
a place with good light so we're still
looking for an office we want an
Instagram e space nothing too big and we
want to make it like a place where
people can come and say hi and very pink
so it fits the feet yes
then I can come take pictures in our own
couches no that still is the funniest
thing I've ever heard that you won't
take pictures in brown and that like or
yellow but now or now that I'm really
committed to the flow and your time here
help me step up my game and now I'm on
the preset grind so I really feel like
I'm at like the level the blogger level
even though what I don't do that I'd
like to help the flow is I should be
using the same preset on every photo
even if it's not totally right but that
I just I can't sacrifice the quality of
the photo and so now I'm like my my feet
isn't totally cohesive but it's bright
and vibrant and I do feel like that's a
reflection of what you can get if you're
gonna follow me yes and you don't need
to always have the same preset it's okay
I think that's fine okay as long as it's
not like one that's like completely you
want like Thai french one bread exactly
right color right just keep it similar I
think you're doing a great job thing
I've been watching and it's like that
bachelorette dress just like makes the
feed yeah it made the theme but now like
winter in New York it's it's a hard time
for for the flows out there yeah it's a
tough time but this show had like the I
tried apartment was like very white and
bright so it's like it helps fill in
spots and then also Theo
whenever I just need like a pop to the
flow I've also been presetting his
photos perfect and it's premium love it
and you're going to Miami there's the
pop of color and I'm gonna use like a
like a 1 preset family for that trip
yeah so what pieces do you use do you
make your own I do not use presets
sometimes if I do I've used them before
I use my friend fashion lashes okay she
has great presets if you guys want to
check out presets like they're amazing
she's so talented okay I don't use
presets I just edit the way I like to
edit so I'll pop the white yeah now I've
learned about like that and how you can
like change colors yeah like you can
exaggerate one color and like mute
another I just learned about that darker
recently dark blue I've always been
using darkroom and now I do darkroom
first get the picture to be the best
version of the picture just in life okay
and then I use presets to make it more
instagramming I'm really proud of you
honestly like I could shed a tear and
I've learned about darkroom from you
when we went on your podcast like that
really changed like that was probably
the
change that I need I think your feeds
looking amazing thank you well yours is
yours looks amazing and thank you damn
thing it's pink and it's you
it's very bubblegum it really is it's
pink black and white pink black white
blonde platinum no no very exciting
stuff um okay so many people want to
know more skincare items on a budget
dr. Dennis Gross has amazing products
you guys I'm like I really am obsessed
with him because he's actually in the
lab he's a scientist and so they don't
break the bank if you're gonna start
with one I would start with the
exfoliating moisturizer okay keep
Somerville's exfoliate have you tried
that it's the best exfoliator like
amazing exfoliator I'm obsessed with
that Cetaphil people say it's cheap and
at Target it's okay okay but honestly I
would remove your makeup with grapeseed
oil and then after you removed your
makeup and like what your face I would
put more grapeseed oil on and do facial
massage that's my cheap like cheap tip I
did that when I had no money in my bank
account it works great and then of
course stay out of the Sun you know how
I'm about that yes oh so um your gifs on
jiffy yes do you guys have Jeff no but
I've been using yours for the past 24
hours like abusing them I'm obsessed
with them you need Jeff's was it easy -
yeah I'll talk like give you all the
details it's like I found an artist
um at carat me home and she's like a
young girl and she designed them and
then you submit them to Instagram you
meet you guys need you know totally and
yours are amazing I just wanted to plug
them because I've been thoroughly
enjoying them I think you need to dress
nicer me yes your the visor one was what
maybe eating a salad maybe that'd be
cute we'll get on it and then one last
question weight loss tips what we talked
about intermittent fasting but like what
what is your diet like and what would it
what is your metabolism I think if you
didn't pay attention to what you eat
like I've gained weight okay 100% um I
would gain weight I carry it a little
like differently I think cuz I'm pretty
tall but I would gain weight if I just
didn't think about it is some
I totally think about I try not to
obsess over it but I do intermittent
fasting five days a week so I stop
eating I eat really late so I'll stop
eating at 10:00 and then sometimes I
don't eat until 1:00 but I drink coffee
with inulin powder in it I get it from
this girl named um I don't her Instagram
handle if you search on on mine is at
Ingrid and you'll find her okay and so
ten to one isn't that crazy
no it's not crazy yeah it sounds crazy
you guys but once your your metabolism
is trained it's not hard at all and for
me I used to be so stressed shoving
breakfast down my throat that it up my
cortisol and I actually think it made me
gain weight so giving my digestive
system that break was super powerful and
just sleep late yeah sleep late drink
your fiber coffee and by the time you
get to one I just do a lot of vegetables
a lot of protein a lot of fiber I eat so
much fiber do you do a factor I do have
factor
I love GG crackers I eat them all the
time but I actually don't think of them
as like a food group I think of them as
a vehicle for other foods I agree it's
like a fork yeah it's just like I'm
getting fiber and to clean me out yeah
and then you know I'm gonna make
something else tastes better
totally and like I'll make a smoothie
for Michael and like put the sprinkles
in there so he doesn't know I might like
[ __ ] his pants at work like you can like
hide it really easy you don't even know
sounds just like the most patient I
don't know about patients like just like
these patients like that is so cute yeah
I don't know about patient but you cook
he's good do I cook
no I'm I my meals are all 5 second
things yeah like like mash berries in
like 5 seconds everything's 5 seconds no
honestly seem yeah I seconds are snacks
yeah or like gotta go you know for
something lots of water try to go low on
the alcohol intermittent fasting I
workouts a fiber I work out all the time
like every day I have an appointment in
my calendar seven days a week but I was
just went off no I don't know what that
was
something but I normally hit five days a
week I think when you have an
appointment in your calendar though it
holds you more accountable you know what
I mean yeah and you won't like schedule
something and then say I didn't have
time yet do it with a friend you're
really lucky though cuz you can walk in
New York that's true and you know what
it seems as though they're forcing us to
walk without the traffic that this is
what they want us to do is walk more do
you count your steps um I check when I
would I think I've walked a lot I look
at my steps nice your goal like a good
day for me is seven thousand steps
that's good
I think that's realistic and fair yeah
it's like unless I'm at a music festival
I'm not gonna hit 10,000 steps yeah
we're a concert I step I guess cuz I'm
always shuffling while I dance they all
count as steps yes I have so many steps
at concerts yeah that totally counts and
you know if you're at home and you're
like oh my god I have to work but I want
to get my steps in take your phone on
the treadmill and just walk at 3.0 put
the incline up a little Janice Dickinson
the world's first supermodel always
walks at an incline so put the incline
up walk and just do emails for an hour
that's actually like a very good idea
honestly I do that all that I have a gym
in my building so I have no excuse not
to just use your Instagram or have sweat
you don't sweat walking so like you
can't sometimes I can't work out because
I am NOT in the position to sweat you
know like either I got a spray tan I got
my hair done spray tan struggle or I
have somewhere to be but that's a really
good idea honestly I even go on the
treadmill sometimes I call it the wrong
word what does the treadmill yeah
treadmill treadmill I thought you said
it wrong I was like I'm not gonna call
you outfit oh yeah I even do lymphatic
drainage on the treadmill oh my god no
no yeah it's a Mel Wow just like you you
can use your time efficiently listen to
a podcast do lymphatic drainage return
emails and WOD get your steps in listen
to the morning toes listeners your
morning toast well thank you so much for
joining us thank you for having me I
honestly love coming on this show I've
you I learn so much I'm so saying for
the next time you come on to see like
where I'm at in my drainage and my shape
and where Sophia riches are and where
Sophia Richie's at exactly
we the North remembers thank you all so
much for tuning in we'll be back
tomorrow with Claudia before we head off
to Miami for hashtag live goes mi a so
we will see you then
have a great day you can follow Lauren
at the skinny confidential for now but
she might be rebranding so go find her
now and you can always follow me at
Jackie O problems you know if you really
really want to and you can follow us at
the Morning Post
so until then we'll see you tomorrow bye
guys
you